think about the audience that's watching
this who doesn't like Andrew Tate and
think about the audience here that's
watching this that loves Andrew Tate and
then there's some that are in the middle
like I don't know I'm just trying to see
what's going on here is he guilty is he
not I'm just like I like some of the
stuff he says there's some stuff I don't
agree with but I'm more neutral similar
to politics Left Right middle right what
would you say to the people like what do
the people uh oh who think this is uh
somebody who is guilty what what should
they go look at like is there any
articles is there any things to follow
what what can they do because there are
a lot of people screaming off the top of
their lungs that these guys belonged in
jail for the rest of their lives and
there are those that are saying they
don't on the opposite side being very
supportive about it what do you say to
the people saying no these guys are
guilty they need to be done they need to
go jail and stay there forever
two points I want to make on that first
of all I think people need to focus not
on you know the content of their speech
whether they like or agree with what the
brothers are saying I think there's you
know some other critical things that you
need to think about which is the fact
that do we believe people should be
detained
when they haven't even been criminally
charged is it right to keep someone in
jail for several months when there is
not enough evidence to charge them at
the time
um that's that's one thing second of all
do we want to start criminalizing speech
you know are we putting people in jail
trying to so that we can try to
reprogram them I mean that's not what
our justice system is supposed to be and
so we're trying to keep the system
accountable and that's not you don't put
someone away seize all their assets you
know try to get them to break so that
they come out and they don't say the
things they were previously saying and I
feel like that's something that seems to
be happening in this case because
there's you know a number of people who
don't or I should say a big uh portion
of people who don't agree with their
messaging but that's something that
should be addressed in a different way
not through the criminal justice system
that's not where you debate ideas and uh
it's it's not an appropriate use of the
system as far as what people could look
at or you know read to to learn more I
would just say that I I think a lot of
the things that Andrew says are taken
out of context I think
you know you'll always see that a one
little phrase that says misogynist you
know Andrew Tate believes women are
property and then if you actually sit
down and watch his long-form interview
he puts everything in context and you
know he says no I believe women are
equal I think when I when I said that
what I meant was you know in a religious
way the way somebody gives you know the
father gives away the bride so you know
he'll explain a lot of what he means and
I think it makes a lot more sense when
you hear his long format interviews
rather than just hearing you know
reading a headline or seeing one little
clip of something he said taken out of
context which I don't think accurately
reflects what his messaging is and I
think if you watch enough of his content
you realize that the overwhelming
majority of the things he says is you
know are things that I don't think
anybody
um disagrees with I think it's all meant
to be motivational and it's trying to
get young boys and men but it applies
equally also to women just to be the
best version of themselves and to work
hard and to live their best life and not
to be lazy and you know there's a lot of
positive messaging that people relate to
and I think it's a very small fraction
of the things he says that are
controversial so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]